OUTFRONT tonight, Putin's mysterious
shake up.
The Russian
president suddenly
putting in a new general to oversee war
warned Ukraine.
And there is a huge question tonight,
which is why What is this all about?
Because it comes
as Russia
claims its forces are on the verge
of seizing the town of Solider.
CNN is there,
has heard the heavy artillery fire.
We're going to show you in just a moment.
It is artillery fire
that has decimated an entire town.
Let me just show you some new before
and after pictures
just in to our field team
on the ground
here you can see a neighborhood
with homes and apartment buildings.
Let's show you now.
Look at that.
Nothing there.
Only the outer shell of buildings remain
even where there's that.
And let me show you another one.
Homes and a school to the right.
Small town now gone.
Everything has been destroyed.
And the fate of this town
that you're looking at right now
solid is at the heart
of this mysterious putsch and Putin's
military command.
Here's what we know happen.
The head of the brutal Wagner
group of Jenny Prigozhin
posted a picture on Telegram,
along with the claim
that his forces,
this private paramilitary group,
have taken control of the, quote,
entire territory of Seoul at are.
Now, you'd think that
the Russian military
would be happy to hear that.
But now they denied promotions, claims
the top Kremlin spokesperson
this morning
saying solidarity is not yet
in Russian control,
that there's only a positive trend.
It is an odd, conflicting message
in a time of war.
It is a mystery.
It's a sign of something much deeper.
And it appears to be at the center
of Putin's general shakeup
because the man that Putin
has now picked to run his invasion.
General Valery
Gerasimov, is backed
by the Russian military establishment,
which has failed
so miserably in so many parts
of this war,
backed by Putin's
minister of defense, Sergei Shoigu,
and the man that Gerasimov is replacing,
General Sergei Shoigu, a week
and has the backing
of Evgeny Prigozhin of the Wagner group.
So tonight in this play, this chess game
it is Advantage Shoigu
and this duel between him and Prigozhin
for the ultimate power
in Putin's
military power and Putin's regime.
So Putin today,
to your point
about the personalities here,
announcing his fourth general
in less than a year
to oversee the war
in Ukraine, specifically,
which obviously is not a good record,
but the man who is now in charge
or Asimov
actually was the person running
the Russian military
over the past decade,
a military
which we have all seen its performance
on the battlefield.
So what do you think
of this, of Gerasimov
now suddenly being entrusted
with this top command
and replacing service, Ken?
It is a bizarre move, Erin.
You know,
it would be the equivalent
of taking the chairman
of the Joint Chiefs, General Milley,
in the United States
and putting him in the front lines
of an operational campaign.
He has been at the forefront of,
as you just said, the Russian military.
That's not just Army,
that's Navy, Air
Force, Naval Infantry, all those things.
So it may be a foretelling
of an attempted future attacks
in different areas of operations
with Navy and air forces.
But I believe it's again,
it's it's a personality driven move.
It is, in fact, a demotion
for Grossmann,
someone who's been in Moscow
for the last ten years.
And it's also a demotion of civilian
who actually was given
the command in the front
for the Russians
and didn't do all that well.
So it's it's
troubling to me and it's confusing to me
why Mr.
Putin did this,
other than potentially to place blame on
some off
who is considered
an insider in the Kremlin.
All right.
Thank you very much, General Hertling.
And OUTFRONT now,
Crystal Grows, the lead
Russia investigator
for Bellingcat,
who identified the Russians
involved in poisoning Putin.
Opposition leader Alexei Navalny
Christo was just placed on
Russia's wanted list.
So, Crystal, let me just start there.
This just happening here
over these these past days.
Why do you think Russia and Putin now
have just put you on the wanted list?
Well, new year, new priorities, but
I don't know.
The answer is there's no explanation.
Our lawyers
my lawyers have not been able
to get any answer as to
why would the charges,
what it says on the most wanted.
The announcement is his been
put on this list
for a violation of a Russian law.
And it's completely anonymous.
There's no way for me to defend myself
from an anonymous charge.
The lowest can find out.
The Bulgarian government
and Bulgarian citizens
have been asking Russia to explain why
and they're not giving the answer.
I think it's a fatwa of some sort.
I mean,
it's like a message that
to other journalists as well
that don't comment on meddling to
do investigations with Russia.
And yet you continue to bravely do it.
You continue your investigations
and you,
more than anyone know
at what possible cost.
Yeah,
we investigate
that, you know,
a series of assassinations
done by the Russian state.
And we one of them
is an attempted assassination on Navalny.
But many other opposition
figures who were targeted
by the same security services in Russia,
some of them with a fatal outcome.
So Navalny
right now, I will ask you about that.
He he is.
You've got new details
surrounding his poisoning.
What are they?
Well, I mean, it's more details
as to the picture that we together
with CNN kind of painted
two years ago, almost
We found out a little more details
that showed the effort
that the Russian government
went into to destroy the evidence
of what they had just done.
There are more people
that were sent to clean up after
after the poisoning.
And also,
what we find out is more evidence
that they were trying to
do something
to the other people
around the same apartment.
For example, Maria Patrick,
who is the lead investigator. Yes. Yes.
I mean,
we see members of the security services
going to her hotel,
a couple of days before the poisoning.
And we're still trying to find out why.
But there's more more granular details
as to exactly how they ran the operation.
Will publish an update soon.
All right.
So let me ask you about Putin
and the news that we have today
that we're talking about
this new commander for Ukraine.
General Gerasimov,
of course, a name
that many have become familiar with.
But he is a person that the
Viognier group chief
Evgeny Prigozhin,
has disparaged publicly.
Right.
A real split there, Prigozhin
with huge ambition.
And now suddenly the person who hasn't
sort of been his
is his nemesis on
this is getting this big promotion.
What does this mean?
Well, it means a couple of things.
One thing it means is that
by promoting
the chief of staff of the Army
to the position of a field commander
essentially running the show,
you can't anymore call this a non war.
You can't call it the special operation.
It's a real war
and sort of it's come out finally.
Second thing is
that Putin has been between to power
to see in the middle of a power struggle.
And Prigozhin actually showed his teeth
in show
that he wants a piece
of a piece of the action,
wants to be in power.
But Putin ultimately
had to take the side of the entity.
Prigozhin establishment,
which is the military establishment,
to show your team the grasp of team.
And what you see now is both sides are
upset with with with this outcome.
And Prigozhin is going to do something,
I think more to claim power,
more dramatic, more power.
So we should be watching that
in the next couple of days.
I think there will
be more lashing out by him.